okay what up guys welcome to the just
pearly things youtube channel i'm just
gonna look for a hot second and make
sure this is working because sometimes
my lives are like a little bit finicky
okay perfect perfect that's what it is
okay so today we are going to be talking
about tom brady
and i just found out who his wife was
today giselle
bundt
and
i find out today that they might be
getting divorced and this was a shock to
me because
i don't know a lot about football
i don't really watch it
but what i do know is that this man
seems
like very religious wait hold on
share our screen
so him getting a divorce
i'm like what
who
so i'm gonna kind of show you what i
found in front of me can you guys see my
screen
tell me if you guys can see it
just put a yes in the chat if you can
see my screen
put a yes put a yes put a yes put a yes
[Music]
okay i'm just gonna assume you can so
i'm going to start with
are tom brady and giselle
bund bundchen
actually getting divorced one report
says their marriage is suffering a
650 million dollar divorce
is imminent
according to the national enquirer
bundchen and brady are only putting on a
happy face
their obsession with money has put their
marriage in danger a source reveals
their business particularly the
endorsements all hinge on them being the
super happy couple and tom being the
number one guy in the nfl brady's money
streams
rely on him playing on an mvp level and
that's not going to be sustainable
forever an insider says
they don't really have a picture
they really don't have a picture for
what comes when tom's nfl nfl career is
over at least not one that they're
sharing with anybody
the two aren't thinking of vacations
of this family anymore their only
thoughts are how to make as much money
as possible an insider concludes they're
more concerned with cashing into into
the max while they still can which is
needless for a couple who's as filthy
rich as they are
this story is all over the place because
it can't decide what angle it wants to
take it alludes to trouble between tom
brady and gisele
over his career but it actually makes
them sound united in their goals the
story laments their focus on money but
it never says either is sad about the
circumstance
furthermore the story repeatedly says
brady must be a good player for the
family to make money while also
highlighting how rich the family already
is buddhichen was able to retire from
her extremely lucrative career so brady
should be able to do the same if he
chooses to be an analyst there isn't a
network on television television that
wouldn't bid from his services
um okay so
there this article is saying that tom
brady and her are not getting divorced
so i guess i'm getting like mixed
mixed input here
tom okay this one says tom brady plans
to file 650 million dollar divorce
against giselle
buddha chin because of this tom brady
mate calls it qui may call it quits with
gisele soon over a decade since the
couple got married brady reportedly grew
tired of his wife as she wants him to
retire from football already
unfortunately
the athlete chose no sign of stopping
any any time soon in touch said on the
summer in the summer that the 41 year
old model wanted a reality show to make
her husband retire they reportedly
wanted to work with fox entertainment
to show their lives
aka the kardashians that does not seem
like something their brand would do
however brady's nfl life caused them to
have issues in the past years for buddha
chin doing the show she would strengthen
her marriage however for brady's part he
saw it
as something that could ruin their
relationship all right guys let me know
in the chat
do you think reality tv is good for
relationships
if we let's look at the kardashians does
that
does that seem good for relationships by
the way if you hear a noise my dog
she like snores sometimes
but she's so cute i can't i can't make
her move
um there is no way brady would retire
anytime soon in fact his wife
he's gotten his wife full support for
throughout the years when i would hope
so you're dating it
you're married to the nfl super bowl
champion
when he won the super bowl the model
even shared a heartfelt message to
congratulate him
is this a reliable article probably not
are any gossip articles reliable
but let me know if you think there's one
that i should look at
let me know
because
tom brady reflects on very difficult
issue in marriage amid retirement
discussions
okay having tough conversations well tom
brady and giselle had an enduring
relationship over the years they're not
immune to marital changes can you
imagine not wanting to take tom brady's
last name i don't know
if maybe she was famous before and she
just
kept it
but i cannot even imagine
not wanting to take tom brady's last
name
um while the tampa bay buccaneers
quarterback 44 has balanced the marriage
and family dynamics with his successful
football career he admitted that the
super bowl
super model had to put her career on
hold to manage their household
but that's an issue and it's very
difficult difficult to reconcile without
saying hey it's time to retire the nfl
champion revealed
on tuesday october 26 of his let's go
podcast and i think there's you know
we're coming to the end here too so i
don't want to miss any of the kids stuff
he continued i think my wife has you
know held the house down for a long time
now and i think there's things she wants
to accomplish you know she hasn't worked
much in the last 10 12 years just
raising our family
and kind of committed to being in that
life in boston and moving to florida
okay
all of a sudden i saw my wife and gave
her a big hug the pro athlete recalled
of his post game actions blah blah blah
okay beyond next year i don't know he
later admitted during a september
interview with the wall street journal
maybe it's just a year after that maybe
two i'll have to see where i'm at with
my family that's probably the overriding
fast factor what i'm missing out on okay
guys anyone that's red pillow where what
is he doing wrong
we like men that are what
on their purpose
so what happens if you make her your
purpose
not good things not good things okay
um the football player and
i cannot say her last name bundchen
tied the knot in 2009 before welcoming a
son
he also shares a son with
basically an ex
um
i think one about one phone call that
changed my life was
my friend ed who called me one day and
said i have this girl and i think you
should call her he told wsj magazine at
the time i ended up calling her and
being the love of my life she didn't
pick up actually i had to leave a
voicemail since then the pair have
remained a dynamic duo and celebrated
their 12th anniversary
earlier this year
gisele and tom will be spending time
with their family for their wedding
anniversary they're just happy to be
spending time together at this time
they're aware that the family is
suffering
and have suffer and have suffered during
the pandemic so their focus is just to
make sure their families and everyone is
close them close to them is safe
okay
buchen buchen said how do you say it
okay my bad
so guys for anyone that doesn't know
that's new to my channel the definition
of hypergamy is the action of burying or
forming a sexual relationship with a
person of a superior sociological or
educational background
so basically as women we want someone
of a higher social status
taller than us stronger than us
just like better than us
like we just want to marry someone
better than this and i would say i think
men are a little bit hypergamous where i
think they want someone better looking
than them
typically
but women we value a million things
they're just like is she hot
is she friendly is she nice
is she in good shape done done deal but
women not so much so
oh that's a good thing i should google
that's an interesting so what is her
now is there anyone because she could be
like what do they call it alpha widowed
he was the beta
i wonder how old she was when they got
married let's look at this um
can you guys hear my dog she's kind of
starting loud if it's really distracting
i may put her in the other room
um
okay
business dude
i don't know who that is
never seen him oh you're right he she
did
leo
do you think that was her alpha she
alpha widowed
chris evans oh my gosh
okay so
all of these guys okay how old was she
when she got married is the question
gizelle
um okay wait
[Music]
marriage to tom brady
um
i'm just trying to figure out how old
she was 29 or 30. okay so it was during
her epiphany phase
how
how did they meet um okay
who did she date before tom brady
oh my gosh she dated leonardo dicaprio
for six years
oh my gosh
she must be that must have been her
alpha widow because
um
okay before meeting tom brady um she had
been in a six-year relationship with
actor leonardo dicaprio from 1999 to
2005 however at the end of the
relationship she was under a lot of
stress in dealing with anxiety and panic
attacks as a result she started to
pursue a healthier lifestyle and saw
dicaprio in a different life no more
numbing myself with smoking drinking and
too much work i was becoming more aware
of things i'd chosen not to look at was
i alone
and wanting to do some serious soul
searching oh my god
oh my god
rolo
rolo talks about this
her epiphany phase now
so she's 41 now
um
so
she married
tom brady
she's 4008.
so she's 41. she married tom brady when
oh my gosh i can't do math
um
oh my gosh but how crazy is that that
she literally
married tom brady after leonardo
dicaprio
so leonardo dicaprio got her early 20s
she was partying doing all that stuff
and she's like you know what tom brady
is my dude
tom brady is my guy
that's her beta oh my god can you
imagine big tom brady
and you're seen as
ah none of it no one's safe okay wait
wait
let me let me just make sure
um okay gizelle
jen
married tom brady
what year
because it's not coming up age so
2009
birthday
she was
born in 1980
so wait
wow
29
on the dot
on the dot
and she put aside her dreams
of being a model and whatever to
be at home with the kids that she
resents him
okay 28.29
oh my gosh
pearl likes what guys i've talked about
this i don't discriminate
if tom brady was interested would i like
white boys
yeah what the
what the
oh my gosh color
wild and it literally in this interview
she said
that she
was partying with leonardo dicaprio
okay wait so when did she date let's see
let's see if it's on on
par so when did giselle
and leonardo
wait
gizelle
oh my gosh
i'm not good at names
hey
leonardo
um okay so
so she dated dicaprio when she was 20.
until oh my gosh and then what did it
say before six years
so till she was 26.
that was her alpha
that was her alpha
tom brady is the beta
she was like okay leonardo dicaprio you
are clearly too irresponsible she's
partying with him doing all the stuff
and then she was like you know what
i
i need to find me a beta and she found
tom brady
can you imagine being hot enough
to get tom brady as your beta
that
that's who you see us be oh my god
oh my god god has favorites okay god has
favorites and she
certainly was one of them
she's got a lot of game let me tell you
so then on top of that okay
um this might come as a shock to sports
fans especially considering that brady
has an average salary of 25 million
but
boo
bunch champ bun chen bun chen i don't
know i'm sorry guys
i should have googled how to say her
name
is the richer of the pair by a landslide
she consider continues to model landing
major covers like
vogue
ali l i don't even know
um
and makes big money from the endorsement
deals including recent deals with
accessories
she has an autobiography
okay blah blah blah
so she's worth 400 million
oh my god god has favorites god has
favorites 400 million
for being hot
i know there's more work that goes into
modeling but it starts there
we can't did not it starts there oh my
god
okay so
why is tom brady a beta though when he
got what he wanted out of the
relationship i mean let's
let's just be honest guys
i i i don't know
like it's how she views him right and
this is just you know my analysis and it
really goes with what rollo says
i could be wrong i don't know
but
yes but she she sees him i'm just
curious how much is leonardo
how much is leonardo
dicaprio worth
260 million
okay so
i guess she i guess he's he's worth more
wow
but she was like i can't lock down this
i can't lock down this alpha
and then so then the next thing the next
little digging i was doing
i went to her instagram
now
what do we got here where is tom brady
where is he i see
i see you
okay let's look at this reel
now if i was married to tom brady call
me call me
[Music]
he will be all over my instagram
let me tell you
but he's still commenting so are they
actually getting divorced i don't know
could not tell you
okay then this one
then this one
okay
oh wait okay
um
we got this one no tom when is the last
time
she posted with him there's with her
kids
um
when is i don't tom where are you at
where are you at
pearl's going to get a gen x husband
hypergamy always went is does gen x mean
he'd be younger than me
i don't actually know let's
let's see jen
acts
years
oh so be like an old guy
i don't know
i prefer not an old guy to be honest
that'd be my preference it's closer to
my age but
i'm not opposed we'll see
um
okay where
oh there he is so the last time she
posted with him was
25 weeks ago
oh my gosh i i swear to god if any
if any nfl champion
wants to wife me up
you can have my instagram it's all yours
you can have it
i swear to god you'll be all over it
oh my god
sorry i think i'm funny
um
okay so
dang like this is for real right on
right on timeline assuming this is true
so now
now
am i see she's already doing it
would i would i accept oh my god yeah
then
and yeah call me hypergamy
um okay anyways anyways anyways
um okay am i understanding that tom
brady's getting divorced or is leonardo
dicaprio getting to four hours no
leonardo dicaprio dated
tom brady's wife basically through like
her best year so if you look listen to
rolos
you know his stuff
basically women go for their like alpha
typically between the ages of like 20
and like 26 ish then they dump the alpha
and find a beta
and her beta happened to be tom brady
and during this phase typically
women find god and they stop drinking
they stop partying they're like i'm
ready to settle down now that i've had
all my alphas and i know i can't tame
them
so
that
is what she did because she got married
at 29 which is right during the epiphany
phase right at the end of it
i think it's 2
8 to 35 maybe
um
pearl could be leonardo dicaprio's next
compute concubine oh wait she's too old
i am too old to be his concubine
anyways
and can you believe she didn't take his
last name
which is
a
a thought
of women that like perceive you as beta
because they don't want to take your
last name they're like no no i'm gonna
keep that
i'm gonna keep that now hypothetically
it could be because she was a model like
there's some practicality to it i'll
give people the benefit of the doubt
but
um i would
consider tom and alpha beta and dicaprio
dicaprio appear alpha now look guys okay
so there's some there's some confusion
people will think well how could how
could tom brady be an alpha era beta
it does not mean that tom brady is beta
there are a million girls that would see
him as alpha
as this man is the best i can do
he just picked the girl the one girl
that could see him as a beta to be
honest
he picked the one out of like the entire
world
assuming this is all true you know
now like oh wait let's do that let's do
that
i'm gonna do the pictures tom brady
and giselle because
it's like who leans into who
oh no she's not leaning into him
she's leaning out
oh my gosh this is what they talk about
but here she's leaning in so it really
depends on the picture i guess
i guess it depends hold on
um
let's see let's see let's see
she's leaning into him there
but there he's leaning into her that's
bad we call that bad that's beta
beta behavior
okay guys
okay
so now now i'm gonna do the fun part of
the show i'm gonna stop i'm gonna take
calls
and we can discuss what do you guys
think
do you think
that one this is real
and two
okay wait let me hold on copy the
clipboard
there i'm gonna put the
can i pin this
let me see if i can pin this
according
valerie
according to fresh and fit a lot of rich
dudes competing
for pearls ew don't
little
they're competing who
let me know who
fresh fresh and fit
um
okay
the second one donovan sharp games
i'm sure she leans whatever way is the
lightest best because she's a model
possibly that's possible
okay i'm not saying i have all the
answers but what i am saying is this
falls into what rolo tomasi says i give
credit where credit's due
i always say where the ideas come from
not me
not me
um but yeah valerie call in i would take
your call ma'am i would
i very much would
um if i were time i would have gone to
the junior college
dc can you turn your camera on i'm
really trying to have people put their
cameras on
um
okay wait like can i pause this
also tonight
there's a link
i don't know why can't i pin it
and i'm trying to keep it one at a time
instead of a group tonight because it's
like
sometimes these get
i can't i can't do that many people okay
hello
what's going on pearl how are you doing
i'm good
uh yeah so
well
well first of all i was i was just
thinking as i was looking at this that
this might not even be
this well one question i want to answer
you said that you think men are
hypergamous about getting the girls that
look better than them um men don't we as
men i don't and i've never heard of a
man talk about this or discuss this with
me we don't look at females and think oh
she looks better than me or is she
better looking to me we never compare
the way we look to the way our female
looks if a man doesn't get with a girl
because
she's not better looking to him that's
because he's a five and she's a three or
a four he thinks she's ugly it's not
because he thought about her but he
didn't think that but
i was even questioning if this is a
matter of hypergamy to be honest with
you because a lot of times in the
menosphere we say hypergamy and i think
hypergame is a reason for a lot of stuff
but i don't think i don't think all this
stuff is just automatically hypergamy
but um
yeah
so you you don't think you don't think
men want to get the hottest girl they
possibly can
yeah i think men do that okay possibly
can but what i'm saying is
because they don't compare it to
themselves that's why that's what we're
saying
is about comparing it to you and you
were saying like men want
girls that are yeah
yeah
okay yeah but but um do i think this is
true um
i think that there is some truth to this
because why shane post him in 25 weeks
and this stuff is coming up and it
hadn't been up before so i don't think
it's just a rumor but i do think they're
going to get divorced i do believe that
um the fact that tom brady is the one
initiating it i i don't think it has
anything to do with hypergamy
uh
but yeah i think that just in this day
and age like
i don't understand why people
like he shouldn't have dated that model
that had been with leonardo dicaprio
like in this day and age like
you got to be aware
of the character and morals
of most people in this day and age
like this is the day and age of like we
should say about alpha seed beta
switch up and do stuff like that so
dudes who are celebrities they got to
stop doing that man
like that's why in the menosphere a lot
of times you hear dudes say avoid girls
who are tense because of stuff like this
but really it falls back on people's
characters and values and
because you'll say something about this
a lot like the reason why they say avoid
them is because they're talking about
the majority and they don't have time to
just say well you know some of them
there yeah and there yeah there are but
the majority so yeah
yeah
no i agree with you i think
with girls when they listen to the red
pill that's why like it's kind of
offensive when we first listen to it
but i think once you understand that
people are talking like in concepts and
it's clearly not every individual person
like it's a lot easier to like take in
um
i also think that they're getting
divorced because
i just i don't think these rumors like
that this many publications comes out of
like nowhere you know what i mean like
there has to be something there
shane posted him in 25 weeks now that
right when you was now when i saw that
because i mean who not gonna post tom
brady you know what i'm saying
that's what i said
he'd be all over my instagram i swear to
god
exactly was there any other part to your
question though um you said do we think
it was real and what else um do you
think it was real and so you don't think
this is hypergamy
because he's not saying it's not hurting
me because i don't think it's hypergamy
because tom tom brady's the one
divorcing her and he's divorcing her
because she's trying to make him stop
football
okay i think there's more to it behind
that she must be a real controlling
person because i have hundreds of
million dollars and i was with leonardo
dicaprio you know what i'm saying like
that's what's in the back of her head so
i'm thinking this i think she must have
a really controlling personality because
just straight up like let's be real if a
man divorces a woman we know the divorce
rates if a man is the one who initiates
the divorce
my automatic thought is there must have
been an actual reason for that
and especially if it's a man who is a
celebrity
men especially well even the females
even though they're going to get
something out of it nobody wants to
actually go through that process because
it's not fun to go through for anybody
but tom brady especially
is not going
he don't want his business all out there
people talking about him hundreds of
million dollars on the line
he don't want that are you are you sure
he's divorcing her because i've i saw in
the articles i was looking at i'm pretty
sure one said she was and one said he
was
that's what i'm saying so yeah i didn't
the only thing i heard was you say he
was so okay okay yeah i'm not sure
i know this story is kind of like
like there's a lot we don't know
yeah there is but these celebrities like
what is it like a 70 80 divorce rate
amongst these celebrities
i don't know that's a good stat i wish i
knew that
yeah i heard it somewhere but it i would
i wouldn't doubt if it was true
um because
it's the people with unlimited options
on both sides yeah yeah that's the funny
part is here's the thing
these people
like i have a saying and it's like in
the back of our heads we all know where
we stand like some of these girls will
call themselves nines and tens and same
thing with some guys but like dude you
know whether or not you're a niner like
you know where you stand at and these
people who have unlimited options it's
funny how their options end up running
out and they end up miserable because
nobody has unlimited options like for
example
there's this girl that i know of that's
like very attractive i'm talking about
between the eight and nine at least and
nobody can figure out like she wants to
be married and she's over here like real
attractive so i'm sure talk about the
fact that people will meet her and think
she's 20 when she's 29. she's like she's
a she's one of those people who is
really small like weighs like 110 pounds
she looks just like a kid
and i'm wondering like
very pleasant attitude like why has no
one picked her up yet and it's because
of and i'm and it could be maybe it's
that maybe the right person genuinely
has not came along because that does
exist that's a real thing
but more than likely it's because
her options she she knows that she's
attractive
and she thinks she has unlimited options
and the more and it's actually studies
have shown the more options people have
the worse it is for them in any area
yeah the parent the paradox of choice
right
yep yeah yeah i've heard that well
because i mean she could still probably
get a guy
i wouldn't say on his level but like
not not too far from it i would think
just being as attractive as she is even
at her age
and
yeah that's probably part of it
yeah
it has to be wait valerie call in
call in
this girl is putting i don't
why are all these guys in love with
pearl she's a obvious man-eater i don't
know what a man-eater is but call in
damn
that's rough
call in lady
man-eater
prenuptial
okay you have anything else you wanted
to add or no
no i'm good
okay thanks for calling in i appreciate
it all right no problem
sorry i didn't mean to sometimes i'm
awkward
um
let's see
if he voluntarily surrenders half of his
wealth he'd need to have his rocks in
his hand
she's a troll i know but i'm just saying
like if you're gonna put in the comments
come on come up show your face let's see
it
um
let's see the link is in the chat
i'm gonna look up more articles while
i'm waiting for people to call in hold
up
um
okay tom brady let's see who's divorcing
who because i wasn't sure
uh
no one's called in right now so i'm
gonna share my screen again
share screen
all right
tom
brady so
divorce
who is divorcing who
just gonna check with
um
oh this article says they're putting the
divorce on
hold
um
okay so this says they're putting the
divorce on hold
tom brady and giselle's relationship is
over ups and downs it's just crazy how
similar this is to rowley's like
principle rollo's principles that's
what's crazy
um
okay tom brady and gisele are each
other's biggest fans well
when the tampa bay buccaneers
quarterback is on the field gisela is
never too far behind in the stands and
tom is equally supportive of his wife
on february 7th we'll get another
glimpse of their love blah blah blah
okay but trouble in paradise tom has
been dating actress
oh wait what the
okay wait let me go back i don't i don't
think this is what i'm looking for i
just want to know who's divorcing who
um
to check if anyone
guys call in call into the show is this
hypergamy yes or no
okay let's see a timeline
does she see him as beta yes or no
she's leaning in there
how crazy would it be if he retired for
her
and then she divorced him oh my god
oh my god tom brady seems
tom brady seems to be continuously
considering retirement but also doesn't
seem to be shutting the door on his
football career yet
on
his podcast with co-host jim gray brady
took listeners through his thought
process on what factors he's considering
um i think the point is there's no real
rest for me to figure out what's next
i'll know when i know it's the day after
season i think all of us can just
decompress for a little bit
let me call in the link is in the chat
my friend go ahead
um
as i've gotten older i think the best
part is football is extremely important
in my life it means a lot to me and i
care about what we're trying to
accomplish as a team and my teammates
the biggest difference is now that i'm
older and i have kids and i care about
them a lot as well my wife is my biggest
supporter and it pains her to see me get
hit out there and she deserves
what she needs for me as a husband and
my kids deserve what they need for me as
a dad i'm going to spend some time with
them and give them what they need
because they've been giving me what i
need the last six months to do what i
need to do as i said a few years ago
it's what relationships are all about
it's now not always about what i want oh
no it's about what we want as a family
and i'm going to spend a lot of time
trying to figure out what is next
um
i think that'd be distracting for me my
employment comes not from the
recognition of what i've accomplished as
a player in the league my enjoyment
comes from competition more so than
anything and i was thinking about
competing i wasn't thinking about
anything other than that when it comes
time to think about post career and
second career i'll think about those
things but when you're 44 i guess you
get asked that a lot a lot of people
thought i was done playing football in
2015 a lot of people in 2016 said you're
done a lot of people when i left the
patriots see that old that's crazy is he
still the best quarterback in the nfl i
don't know anything about football
i don't
um
okay
um
okay but it's kind of that same dynamic
though right hold on it's kind of that
same dynamic though the
isn't it crazy how the biggest
celebrities have the same problems that
all the normal people have
you work too much
we want you home
i want you to take a less demanding job
and this is the thing
there's nothing wrong with like taking
your wife's opinion into consideration
like you should especially if you've
like a good woman but
there's a difference between that and
like doing always what she wants to do
we are attracted to guys that are on
their purpose
even if we hate it
like sometimes
because it makes us respect you and if
you're just a guy that's like
bending over to what your wife wants all
the time
now
now the question is is he divorcing her
is she divorcing him if anyone has any
links or has anything
i can't find the one article i found
said that he was divorcing her and then
another said she was divorcing him so i
guess we can't know
but then the question is like why are
they divorcing
gallery i'm like waiting for you to call
in ma'am
you're so bold in the chat come on
telling me about kids i didn't know i
had
that's which is crazy
um
peyton manning is an incredible talent i
don't know guys i'm not a sports person
i don't watch sports
so the question is is this hypergamy yes
or no because
everything that i've seen it seems like
it's hypergamy right she had her alpha
guy during the alpha phase she's
partying with him partying with leo
breaks up with him finds her beta guy
and if you look at rolo's chart this is
around the alpha free interest period i
want to say it's like early 40s because
the kids are big enough she got what she
wanted
with a face like peyton you better be a
good quarterback
i'm from the uk and i know peyton
manning that's how great he is i look it
i have no doubt i'm sure
i just i don't
i'm not a
i'm not a football type of girl i don't
it's not my thing
who's the father of her child i don't i
don't have kids guys
not yet anyway someday
what's interesting is that it's not a
money thing
um
is that it's not a money thing in my
opinion tom has no worries about money
um no it's that's what i always say on
the channel it's literally not about
money
it's literally not about money
um
shoot your shot in tom's dms i don't
think tom
would look my way that's funny
that is funny
okay
valerie either call in or i'm banning
you from the chat come on put your money
where your mouth is baby
what up mac
hey um just calling in real quick it's
kind of speaking of like football it's
kind of the nfc championship so it's
like uh
probably not the best time but hey we're
here just real quick um
is that hypergamy i don't i'm
struggling to think why i mean he's won
seven rings
has as
much money as anybody could want
practically
i mean for a
55 year old man he's
just doesn't look how bad
and i believe her
his wife is uh gazelle munchen
and she's
she was a pretty up there model
i think she's
37 now
so this whole idea like oh you know
break up with the beta played a field um
she's 41. oh wow yeah a little bit
yeah she's it's not exactly old i mean
young so
i mean
i don't know um
so just so you know when we're talking
about is it hypergamy it doesn't mean
that like most girls won't find someone
beta and it doesn't mean that like the
guy necessarily is beta it just means
that
that woman views him as beta
and i'm gonna just give you the case as
to why i think it's hypergamy but you
you're welcome to like give the case as
to why you don't
so i i think that um
leonardo was like her alpha widow i
think that's who she viewed as alpha and
if you look at the timeline of like
rollo's chart it's just kind of weird
how
similar it was to his chart of like when
a woman like switches from the alpha to
the beta because she broke up with him
at about
26
yeah
and then at 29 she married tom brady
which is like right around the epiphany
phase and if she divorces him that's
right about the alpha re-interest phase
so it doesn't it doesn't mean that he's
a beta like i think most girls would
view him as
alpha but it just means that
that like that she viewed him as beta
does that make sense uh
i guess
here's the thing
it's it's easy to say you know alpha
what if people break up for
dozens of reasons i mean he just lost um
a divisional
and he's still talking he was almost 35.
i also want to play football i was like
damn bro
sit your ass down you already won some
rings
so you know
but i mean a lot of that talk he's
probably if he really still wants to do
it a lot of us probably like okay he has
to search for a team he wants to take
him on his draft is going to be in a few
months and
even though that doesn't necessarily
compete with your draft pick it does
compete with cap
cap space and a lot of that so he's
trying to if he's on a play he's trying
to search for a team
so
he is going to he's going to say a lot
of things it's going to be like the new
york uh not new york new england
situation where you know everyone
thought that was retirement everyone
thought gronk was going to retire and
a week ago they were playing uh nfl uh
playoff football so
i don't know uh and how solid are these
rumors about this divorce because i mean
this
came out of left field
oh it's not
it's just i mean in the last couple
months there's been articles about it
but i've said since the beginning this
could not be true
yeah uh i just don't know too much about
them i know they have i think
two kids and i mm-hmm
i don't know
i just
uh but to seek on like why i guess it
kind of doesn't make sense to me is that
um
what kind of
what role is really good at is kind of
really phrasing almost any potential
situation as kind of being what he talks
about
people
divorce for
dozens of reasons and
and i'm pretty sure um
leo uh whatever the other guy name is
ken say right now that she was used
today i think he's caught up so i don't
and he has a very pretty document
history of going after younger women
pretty sure
uh they're both the same age so
uh
i don't know her personally but i doubt
she's dumb and she
was able to be a pretty high power model
for quite long i don't think she's gonna
try to shoot on that
very very long field goal so i don't
know
uh it's i mean yeah it could fall into i
haven't seen this chart it could fall
into it but i mean
right my parents relationships could
have fallen into that um my mom my my
dad were talking about well as well for
my mom we're talking about splitting but
we don't know what goes on behind the
curtains like
because i mean he's been traveling a lot
um well
the last divisional was at their
tampa but still just being when you're
all you're reaching middle age and
you're still an athlete i mean that's
for most uh even for like most so-called
regular people if you're still like a
businessman you're still traveling it
starts getting pretty damn old for the
spouse whoever that is
okay straight blah whatever but you
don't think she knew that going into it
like you married the most like
out of anyone with the odds of like
like staying in the nfl the longest it's
gonna be like the most competitive guy
there is like she you don't think she
knew that he's crazy competitive
yeah i mean it's it's yeah she she
doesn't know but it's like kind of one
thing
kind of signing up for something is
another thing that they've been married
i believe for when it's
i don't know for a while now
but it's another thing to completely
live it and just relationships just get
they get old yeah
no i i actually agree with you when you
say there's a million reasons that like
relationships can end and i do agree
with you that like um
rollo is really good at like phrasing
anything to be honest as hypergamy
like um
but i don't know this one seems like a
very
like it's a little bit too similar for
me to not notice it if that makes sense
like all i didn't even know the ages of
any everything that happened until i
went live
and
it was just crazy how it was like
everything that he says
typically happens does that make sense
yeah i mean i i i'm
being honest i don't really watch his
videos that much i just kind of hear it
there and there so i mean i can't
have the
i don't have the knowledge of what he
says to even refute it so i know i'm
just like sure
no no i just want to i just want her to
pop in real quick i actually want to try
to probably have time now probably miss
a ton of scores but i just wanted to hop
in
okay well thank you so much for calling
and i appreciate it yeah no problem uh
take care
okay bye
okay valerie um you need to put your
camera on hon
i will you will be the first one added
when you put your camera on
first one i am waiting
[Music]
okay someone said they have very they
have completely different backgrounds
um
valerie i said that at the beginning of
the stream
before the first guest came on you can
go back i said put your camera on to the
first guess
second guess
came on with her camera on now i'm
waiting on you
um
[Music]
let's see
all right you want me on camera so you
can humiliate me
um
are you ugly i don't know i can't number
one and number two i want you on camera
because if you're gonna say some out of
pocket [ __ ]
then stand on it
show your face like don't hide behind
the camera
i'm actually quite nice to be honest
i don't
i don't go after people for the looks i
think that's trashy actually i think
that is trashy behavior
um
but come on grow up here put your camera
on
or someone else call in
is there a football game going on now
this is how you know i don't watch
football
football game
blocker she obviously won't call in
but no i actually the camera thing is
new because
i can't i can't deal with people that
won't go on camera if they're gonna say
out of pocket stuff
i did start that this live stream
but i did that for every caller
so you are not special
[Music]
all right the gray pot ill podcast
fine you'll leave
because you don't have balls okay that's
what i thought
uh okay next person
hi
hey what's going on how are you i'm
doing dandy
so what do you think about the topic
tonight
uh you got to kind of update me a little
bit on the topic i was streaming through
and i came across you i'm a fan
okay thank you um
so we're talking about tom brady getting
divorced and if it's hypergamy oh wow do
you do you know anything about that i
know of tom brady
so basically he he met his wife um she
married him at 29 do you do you know
rollo's chart
yeah i heard about romo and his uh his
amazing amazing books
it's basically that she married tom
brady at 29 and she dated leonardo
dicaprio until 26. so hypothetically
leo would be like her alpha widow
and she was partying and stuff before
she met tom brady with leonardo dicaprio
he got more spiritual
found god or whatever like her
spirituality whatever
and then
ends up marrying tom brady at 29.
that's a little bit uh the uh the making
good story a little bit
i don't i don't know that story actually
what do you know about megan good
no ah that sounds really familiar i
can't google uh black yeah the the black
famous well she's not really
hero actress they got married to the uh
the pastor for like 19 years
uh somehow it didn't work out and then
she's now she's uh doing his high film
to get her uh i'm trying to be youtube
friendly uh to get her groceries eating
out on film
oh
wow
oh wow um
um
yeah i'm looking at this now i don't
know what age all of that happened at
but
yeah that sounds similar from what
you're saying
so back to tom brady
we're not really making good on the
whole story
yeah but basically um now she's 41 which
i want to say like on rollo's chart is
around the alpha like re-interest phase
so
um
yeah it's like they marry the beta
around like their epiphany phase and
then after the epiphany phase like the
kids are a little older it's like the
alpha re-interest so they want to go
back to the alpha i guess
that sounds like a
a cute way of saying
like for example like how are you
i'm 25. okay cool so that's like saying
you meet your boyfriend
around the 20s and he has potential and
then he gets get everything he needs to
become he might become president
of top lawyer might be in the same um
uh financial field as your as your dad
and then 20 years he's like you know
what i'm capping out i'm gonna get what
i get from him i got the family kiss let
me move on does that sound similar to
the whole time brady thing
yeah actually a little bit oh wow
like leonardo was a little too wild for
her to tame basically
i heard loki was a freak though but i
mean i'm just speculating what i heard
lowkey is a freak though but i'm just
well that's the alpha like the
hypothetically right so that's the the
alpha guy is like the one that like
rocks her world and she can't stop
thinking about and then she is like okay
i can't tame him so i'm gonna go marry
the beta
i can't i can't
i know
so and then that's the case say what is
an alpha because me personally i don't
use those terminologies so oh i hate the
terminology but it's just what else do
you call it yeah cause i'm on the fence
like one day i could be like yeah i'm
just that good guy like nobody want the
good guys good guy what's the phrases uh
nice guys finished last so i had my
moments the nice guys finished last and
i got the other moments uh somebody hit
up my dm like hey you wanna hang out
wanna chill or
be savage or just go and kind of date
somebody in the weekend
well it's not it's not necessarily about
the guy by himself it's about
the sex
no no no no it's about how the woman
views the guy
so like 99 of girls are going to find
tom brady like to be an alpha because
that's the best that girl can do like
she has to view you as the best she can
do so because before
in her head there was someone that was
like the actual best she could do
yeah and then she views him as beta
on that note wouldn't we be speculating
though inside her head her mind
about oh yeah think about her because
let's let's keep her honest right now
we're talking about
how she view him financially
you know what i'm saying no it's not
financial it's not necessarily financial
it's like it's what that woman values so
like for example like i know girls in
the church that their alpha would be a
guy that's like a very close
relationship to god
like that's what they value that's at
the top of their hierarchy so some girls
it's looks some girls it's money some
girl it just depends okay
does that make sense yeah so why can't
it just be
instead of just saying alpha why can't
just be like their version of what they
consider a high-value
no you could use that word too yeah
i wrote that i'd rather use it
that's fine i just i use no no i'm with
you it's just like that the alpha the
alpha things like when i hear alpha's
like
oh i know i don't i don't enjoy the
terms like they're kind of awkward but
i'm so used to them now it doesn't even
phase me because i've just listened to
enough of his stuff yeah i hear not just
literally
okay
it is what it is but no i mean at the
end of the day i mean how you say how
long he was married for like what 10 20
years
um
i think she's 41 11 years so she got
divorced at four like is getting
divorced at 41 29 she got married so 11.
yeah she did good i mean i mean i i get
it
maybe there's something down the cusp
like i mean most people do five
um
10 20 and there's something about their
relationship or just inner circles maybe
something worked out for them to keep
the plane pulling because like real talk
marriage is just papers business but if
you want that unity we got to figure
things out as a couple so i mean for her
she lasted 10 11 years great at the end
of the day like
who really cares she had to
whatever drama if it is drama she had to
sleep and live with that he had to sleep
with that
i actually care less now if it was like
some year
she got like you seen the news oh she
got 50 million dollars like okay now
y'all want to do controversy go ahead
11 years
well i think i think the reason people
care is like a lot of guys feel like
because someone actually requested this
topic i don't watch football so i
actually like barely know who he is
um to be honest but i feel bad i'm gonna
throw myself on the bus i'm like the
only guy who don't care about sports
like no i don't i don't care at all like
i don't even know there's a game right
now apparently oh i'm a beta
but i think the idea is like even
even the guy
like
that has everything like everything a
girl could possibly want it's still not
enough for the girl
yeah i think that's the idea that's why
people care
because he didn't get everything he
wanted from her or she didn't do no no
she it was like um sorry
she he had everything like a girl wants
like he's successful he's like athletic
good looking like every everything like
on a list that girls could want
and it still wasn't enough
for the girl i mean then i mean you're i
mean i have friends i know that actually
had like you know
quarter high value in
very successful financially in hell
you're a perfect example of you know
you you pretty much preach like a good
75 percent of time like hey i'm i'm a
wealthy family blah blah blah but
i still consider myself regular regular
so
if she is with this guy again something
in their life clearly
didn't reach that plateau after the 11th
year mark to say hey you know what i'm
tapping out
now is he still in it like i'm now i'm
just acting is he still in that career
what he's doing if so then that's
something that just like got slowly
tapped out like
if you're a movie star an actor so if
i'm if i'm tagging along with you
okay 10 years now i'm kind of getting
like worn out
with that lifestyle like hey i thought
it was going to be us was going to
change
oh for sure for sure but that's that's
oh i know that's the question though
we're just asking like is that hypergamy
that's the question i think it is
because i think it's just a little too
on rollo's timeline i think it's a
little too close for me to not think it
is
but you know i'm old-fashioned i just
think it was just two individuals
that did their bed
uh somebody in their relationship would
say hey you know what it's not working
no more
let's explore the options and that's do
they have kids together
too there you go they did their part
they did they did the best they can
let's go who is who are we to judge
about them again if there's a year
some controversy she got her like a
little 50 million dollars
go at it
go
that's what these shows are we just give
opinions on people okay i'm down for
that
my opinion is 10 years 11 in
who gives a [ __ ] are you sleeping good
at night great are you are you worried
about what she's doing in bed
then you got a problem then you need to
go talk to a therapy a doctor that's my
opinion
not you per se but just anybody else in
general like you need therapy you need
help
anybody else in the chat or anybody else
got like 10 years 11 years of marriage
great let me know how that works give
the other people advice because those
are people that need to help the people
that are doing the one year marriage
i even give you two but if you can go
survive in five years plus
great so nobody should be judging nobody
else especially 10-year loving your
marriage
business okay
well thank you for calling in i
appreciate it oh thank you appreciate it
have a good one you too
okay guys
this is an interesting conversation
i probably should have waited to do this
stream now that i know there's a
football game going on like what the
what the what on earth
um
i was so excited to talk to my troll but
she wouldn't turn her camera on
i was like ready
oh my gosh
guys i'm not on the camp where
it's a hundred percent like oh this is
hypergamy
but
this one it's just a little too close
everything is just a little too close
like
she is saying sir you work too much
that's something you say to a blue pill
um okay say let it be hypergamy with
that said she will be subject to
everything that comes with the decision
with those actions she will see
firsthand what's out there for her
okay here's the thing
sometimes these girls leave and do
better i know you don't want to hear
this guys
now
will she do better than tom brady
probably not probably not but she'll
probably still do fine
to be honest because i mean look at her
she's still hot
how do i respond to the allegations that
i'm a red pill groupie what the what is
the red pill groupie
i like don't even know what that means
[Music]
i googled red pill groupies
this is an old stream
who allegated that
who
where's the allegation coming from i'm
open to it
i'm gonna have to buy a dictionary okay
well sir this isn't a debate
oh my goodness
oh you did sir
the few is not an exception to the rule
no that's true that's 100 true
but i'm saying like i i could see her
being an exception maybe not that she
does better but still does pretty well
because she's hot
big oh
sorry i just you i just figured you were
a male run account
um
uh okay wait i've read let's google red
pill groupie red pill groupie
[Music]
phenomenon of red pill groupies by
dominican sharp
uh
can't find it where does it say that
i see rolo's stream about it but
i don't see the
the actual definition and i don't i
can't watch this on live um
okay just because i think role was a
goofball at time does that mean george
clooney is a beta because he married a
30 year old woman who's out of her prime
no of course not i mean it's all about
does the woman see him as alpha that's
what's important
and
even if she's out of her prime like
there's other factors that come into
play like common interests common core
values like there's more to it than just
age but when you're talking about
generality
gen or
oh my gosh society when you're talking
about society as a whole
like that's what we're talking about
like in general it doesn't mean every
specific person
um
according to you she's hot she's you are
not you aren't the one evaluating her
relationship material
her worth to be in a relationship with
her oh my gosh my dog is sparking
um humbly said gold professor no that's
true that's 100 true
um
oh my gosh can you hear that
she's like having a nightmare it's okay
ellie it's okay
it's okay
i don't know if they're actually getting
divorced i don't know either
but
and this is this is what i mean when
everybody wants
to get the best possible partner they
can
women men will settle and women won't
that's the only difference men will
settle and women won't so when i think
of hypergamy i think of like every girl
wants to do like the best that she can
do
and and most men want to do the best
that they can do too
weather i mean
every person values different things so
it's not
as simple as sometimes the manosphere
makes it where it's like oh if he makes
this much money does this this and this
like you don't you don't know what that
person values
hold up
but i do think
i do think this is hypergamy i'm gonna
be honest
um okay
i was really excited to talk to my first
i actually have been getting hate videos
lately and it's kind of exciting
i kind of enjoyed the attention i'm not
even gonna lie to you
i'm like oh i get a whole video
they're like
oh my goodness um
also guys if you
are
interested i want to do
a live show where i have girls from my
volleyball team come on
and these are girls from all over the
world that come onto the show
and we talk about different relationship
topics the problem is i need a sound
board and i can't afford it right now so
i'm at almost 250 of the 500 goal
so
it's a 500 sound board for me to plug
all the mics into and i i need to order
one more mic too but i'm doing the sound
board that's my first goal
so
if you want to send a donation that is
what it would go to
and
what is something i could give you guys
in return
i don't know
um
that was my first no it wasn't my first
troll but it was my first one that
wanted to like come and talk to me
but i was like you got to be on video
let's fight fair
um
if i gave you
hundred dollars for the sound board
would you would you change your mind
about me
what's my mind about you i don't know
um usually us men die before our
partners so i think
we should do
more to get desirable partners that
aren't [ __ ] with attitude and grounded
i think rolo overgeneralizes too much
and he doesn't talk about the gray areas
oh for sure
for sure but i think he gets a little
more views probably being a little more
divisive of course there's great areas
my problem is sometimes rollo it's like
he always finds a way for it to fit
with his like
narrative if that makes sense so
if a girl
it's like no matter what age the girl
gets divorced at
no matter what age the girl gets
divorced at it always
fits in
does that make sense like if she does it
in her 30s then she viewed him
as beta and it was like the making up
for missing out like there's always a
way for him to
fit it as i recall
um
as i recall you called me a beta simp
with no life i don't think i did
i i don't think that was me that might
have been torso
uh what's my definition of hypergamy not
rolos so my definition of hypergamy is
like women always wanting
like like we always want bigger better
smarter taller stronger and a girl
is never going to be happy with you
unless she views you as the best she can
do
so
if she had like guys that were better
than you before
she won't really be happy she'll bury
you and act happy
and thank you so much for the 5 super
chat i really really appreciate it like
i literally
i literally appreciate it so much
torsha likes me in spite of what i said
about her when i first met i don't
lemonade i don't dislike you
sir
not all women date up but they date up
when they can
all women date up when they can
but not all women can
which is true
that's that's the problem like not all
not all women are able to
but you guys can call into the show but
go on camera that's my only rule
um
best to use a dictionary definition i
agree
i agree
yes some women date or married down of
course
of course not everyone can marry up
like duh
i can't go on camera it would compromise
everything for me okay well then don't
call into my show
sorry
that is my new rule
i
but not all women are able to but the
issue is most
we have is most of them think they can
it's the perception of options that's
messing them up
um that's why i said new rule and say
old rule i said new
rule
not old rule
if you look back to my guests today each
and every one of them i said the same
thing
um
this has more to do with with brady not
making time for his family and his wife
the amount of time works he put into
what football of course he lacks in
other areas now that would
hypothetically
that would hypothetically be a theory
right but
why now is it a problem
and also you you knew who you were
marrying
like he was well into his career when
she picked him
don't really make sense
um you're john i actually
didn't hate that boot camp like i
thought it was helpful
i wouldn't pay that much
but i'm also cheap like if i had the
money and i was a guy and i thought it'd
help me
um i think that's my most underrated
youtube video though i spent so much
time editing that
just to like not make the money back
that i spent on it to be honest
um
because he is nearing retirement and he
would bore her to death like yeah out of
all the times that she would divorce him
why why now
when he's closer to retiring than ever
like she
except when women tell me their
preferences even if they aren't done
pieces and i'm i'm not up to that tall
dark handsome card that's okay i'll
never date down as men i have standards
okay good date up for looks married for
looks even if the guy's broke
you think that's what we do
i don't think that's what we do
um
yeah she complained when he was working
and now she complained that he's not
it's about to get bad for brady she's
about to take him to the cleaners
brady is soon to be no longer the guy
she
married
even though he's exactly the guy that
she married
we say what we want we don't even know
what we want the thing is i think a lot
of people don't know what comes with
that lifestyle and this is what i i can
say from dating someone that is famous
um it's not really fun having
girls all over him all the time
you know it's like that when i
was dating one yay when i was like
rihanna was in his dms you think that's
like fun
um i can't even imagine tom brady like
the amount of
that guy gets thrown at on the daily
how is pearl so easy going yet so picky
i didn't trash everyone the first guy
said smash
there's three
the first one i said smash and i said
pass pass
like
smash pass that's one for three that's
like 33 percent
sir
don't
if i rejected you just say that
um
hi pearl if you're gonna require
everyone to be on camera maybe perhaps
use zoom or we can see them without
having to display
having to display them on youtube
oh that's a good idea
maybe next time i will i didn't think
about that um
i love girls that like anime gamer girls
call me sir one more time i call
everyone sir but your name is bobby
i remember the singer adele got divorced
she lost millions she married down
that's true she did
couldn't be me
couldn't be me i
i'd get prenup or something if i was
adele
could not be me
i refuse this fuse to be a man who
compromises himself financially
physically mentally blah blah blah so
she can kick rocks and okay
it's the female spelling okay ma'am
chill
uh
besides brady himself has said that
since he's pushed back retirement that
giselle has several convos with him
about
eventually settling down with the family
you can't expect people to wait forever
he has nothing left to prove but he
keeps playing it's inherently selfish
but she married the selfish guy she knew
he was selfish
she knew that she knew that when she
married him that he was going to want to
play forever you picked the most
competitive
man like on the planet
and now you're like oh he works too much
like
of course he works too much
look what
that's who you married you know how many
normal guys
she could marry she's hot
she knew women don't think that far
ahead okay well then that's her own
fault
you appreciate my broadcast thank you
rioso if you want to call in um make
sure you turn your camera on i'm doing
cameras on today
oh my gosh thank you so much for the 20
we're at 270
out of the 500.
270. thank you
thank you so much
thank you thank you thank you you're my
new favorite person
shout out to sam
i'm sorry oh no
mendy massa
i hope i said i'm sorry if i didn't
yeah i was trying to say it's not always
about money if you're good-looking with
no money a girl will still marry you
true it's another form of a hypergamy i
was just agreeing with what you said
before yeah that's true
it's about what the girl values you have
no idea what that female values
like
something i value a lot is like
political party association like most
girls don't give a [ __ ] about that
but that's like really important to me
like you either need to not care or you
need to agree with me
because otherwise we will not get along
at all
because i just won't think you're very
smart
um
respectfully like in the most respectful
way i can
well you still gotta make money oh my
gosh you can't be a loser
um
you can't like if you're a loser it's
not gonna go well
what party well i'm not gonna tell you
guys on on camera
um how could she know he wanted to play
forever that long ago when he keeps
pushing off retirement every year that's
not what she signed up here
for brady today is in brady 20 years ago
how could she
how could um
i just
i just think if you if you marry the
world's best quarterback you kind of
know that comes with the job
um if we thank you for the donation
thank you for the donation thank you so
much i'm going to count that as 20. so
we're at 2
2 7 2 9 d out of the 500
that we need for
the
sound board
thank you guys
oh my gosh we're getting so close
if i call in can we talk about the
political party thing we can talk i
don't want to like go into too much with
that we can talk about like me valuing
that if you want but
like i don't know it just depends what
the girl values but
but for real thank you guys so much like
you guys have been so nice
with everything when i when i get the
sound board i need to order a soundboard
and a new mic
and i'm hoping i'm working really hard
this month i swear to god i'm working so
hard i've been posting a million videos
hoping that one takes off
i've been very disappointed so far but
one of these days i swear to god
something is going to take off because
like
god willing please
a green party voter what the
i don't even i don't even know what the
green party is
hi zach hey what up
how are you i'm good yeah i don't know
what the green party is myself i'm not
not super up to date with those sort of
things
so what's that what what you said you
wanted to talk about the political party
thing
yeah i was hoping you would elaborate
more on that what you said back there
oh it's just like when i'm
most girls don't really care about
politics so when they're looking at like
things they value and look for in a
partner that's not even on the list
because most girls don't care that i
talk to
um
however i do care
and i don't think i would date someone
that felt really strongly in the other
direction i've dated guys that like
don't care about politics and don't
follow it but like i like that's
something i value and i'd like to me
that's like a core value
yeah i always found it kind of strange
just how many people either don't care
or claim they don't care
like those are literally your values
yeah that's what i think but i mean i
think some people just don't follow it
like they just think it's boring and
they don't vote like a ton of people
don't vote
yeah that's annoying i remember back in
2016 which is the first year i was able
to vote i guess you were two since we're
the same age
but i remember hearing about this um
this couple and they were kind of on
opposite sides of the political spectrum
what was going on back then it was kind
of framed as a love story like
you know we put our differences aside
and we can still make it work but i'm
thinking to myself like
you believe opposite things like how are
you going to raise your children if you
have them
i mean i've seen people make it work but
they're usually people that don't feel
that strongly in either direction one
just kind of leans one way and one kind
of leans the other
but like neither of them are like have
that strong of opinions
yeah that's fine it's just when it's so
polar opposite i don't see how you even
make i even pretend to make that work
yeah no i agree that's why i don't
i don't do it
but um now most girls i talk to like
that's not even on their radar to be
honest
a question is that girls you talk to in
england or just in general
um i'd say girls like from home
like that i grew up with um in england
most of the girls that i talked to
already had boyfriends so
like i don't know
i was just wondering maybe the political
climate was a little different there
because i hear they have more than two
parties like they have more than a
two-party system
well most of my it's you i'm kind of in
an american bubble so most of the girls
i talk to are actually american because
like the whole team is american at least
for uel anyways
okay
yeah i see
uh did you want to discuss the brady
situation too or
yeah if you want to um do you think it's
hypergamy
uh somewhat i mean it kind of has to be
right
that's sort of what we believe around
here that
that's kind of what goes
but even then it's like
but how is it though because from what i
understand he makes um excuse me she
makes more money than him
mm-hmm i mean
he is tom brady though so is it maybe a
status thing mm-hmm
yeah but i think it's that like when he
retires he's gonna lose the status
definitely a little bit yeah that's how
it goes yeah
um
so that's like i think what the the
outcry kind of is it's like this man has
everything and he still wasn't enough
for her almost because now she's
complaining that he's not home enough
yeah it's always the one thing you
you're laughing like that
you have 90 of what you want and then
that other 10 percent you're always kind
of looking at it over your shoulder
yeah
and i think it's that like she dated leo
before so maybe she looks at him as like
oh she was one of his
yeah yeah she dated him for six years
like 20 to 26. yeah that had to be
a long time ago right because he only
dates like the 22 year olds or so here
yeah i mean she broke up with him when
she was 26 or he broke up with her
whatever so i guess she out aged him
yeah leo's like the one celebrity that i
can think of that is like that like the
others they sort of all maybe they had
their phone when they were younger but
they eventually kind of matured and
got married not that either way is
correct but
he seems like the one that's still kind
of doing his thing
still yeah well i think
because like the way that girls like
view alphas like they can't lock that
like th the theory anyway is like they
can't they can't lock the alpha down
right so when she's like okay i can't
lock him down i'm gonna like find
hypothetically the beta and like tom
brady just picked the one girl that
would view him as beta out of like the
million that wouldn't like literal
millions that's weird right like do you
think he does that on purpose or did it
just happen
no i mean
i think like it's just more likely the
hotter the girl
you know like models date
most models date rich and famous men so
it's kind of hard to be the best it's
kind of it's it's kind of hard to be
like the best that
the girl has had
when you're competing with like a ton of
rich and famous men because girls that
hot have access to them
yeah it does seem that way
yeah
i mean so what was it for them they just
uh she was just the best one to him
i guess i didn't look too much about
their relationship i more looked at like
her past so she dated um
she dated leo from 20 to 26 and
basically was like partying and stuff
with him and then after that she like
got spiritual which is like you know
epiphany phase
stop stop stop doing that stuff and at
29 she married tom brady
okay that makes sense yeah now she's 40
you know she's 41 and apparently
i don't know i've seen articles that say
tom brady's divorcing her i've seen
articles that say vice versa so i don't
know who is divorcing who you know the
thing about that
um i didn't find out about his
retirement until like last night and
even then i was seeing articles that
said you know
it was kind of conflicting like is he
retiring we don't really know yet so
i'm just kind of waiting to see how that
unfolds
yeah yeah i think yeah we don't know
like i'm kind of like that with news in
general it's like whatever i see like if
it's real it'll come back around
yeah and if it's not it won't
yeah and that's the thing even with the
divorce we don't know for sure
but i don't know i there's got to be
something i think there's too many
articles for it to just be based on
nothing i think there's something but
that's what i'm saying actually if it
yeah if it's real it comes back you're
not just gonna see it in one article
everyone's going to jump on it
yeah no for sure
um well thanks for calling in i
appreciate it
yeah
see ya
okay guys
um
so
debating if i wanna how long have i been
on the stream oh gosh hour 40 minutes
um
okay i think i'm going to bed it's kind
of late it's almost two in the morning
um
he doesn't retire i can see him
divorcing her i guess we will find out
okay thank you guys so much for the
donations i for real appreciate it so
much so much so much so much like
it's been really tough on youtube lately
and
just having you guys like
send in donations for this sound board i
think this show is going to be great
i am going to be able to bring in girls
from all over the world and ask them
their opinions on different things i
kind of want to do what fresh and fit
did and like make my living room
a
like like a studio type setup and
yeah i'm going to bring in girls from
all over the world i think it's going to
be really cool
um actually i'll do one more caller just
because this is the guy that inspired my
stream hi
hey pearl can you hear me
yeah hi how are you what's going on so
i
i just saw this here going live and just
keep because i i always just had a
conversation with us about this with my
friends and i haven't done done done any
research but
giselle is worth 400 million dollars i
think he went over that tom brady
250. now
hypergamy states that
you know they shouldn't even be together
uh
in the first place based upon wealth but
i remember you know i'm older than you
but like i think
there's a study in the late 90s or early
2000s
saying that the number one job any man
would
i think it's like 18 or like 40 would
want to have in the united states was an
nfl quarterback like all men wanted most
men in the united states could only
dream to be
uh nfl quarterbacks so what i think what
made up the the difference in worth
was
his status as tom brady
and now that's going to be gone
mm-hmm so
we're just talking about dude give it
two years man and and we're like whoa no
they suck it up this part he's gonna go
from tom brady one of the greatest
leaders of
you know of men outside the military to
just tom brady with uh with a broadcast
gig
you know at home all all the time
with the kids and and people could say
well she could be happy with his career
but
this is the cell blocking she's been
told she's been i don't know how many
times she's gotten like the most
beautiful woman on the planet but like
she got
400 million dollars a 400 million dollar
worth
you know
based upon her looks pretty much mm-hmm
so
i don't think they're gonna make it
uh i i i
i i don't know if he's gonna and then
there's a study that said that 90 of the
time if a man's status changes
or if a woman gets like a promotion or
makes more money the woman leaves
oh really 90 is it that high it's like
80 or 90
wow that's crazy i did not know it was
that high
i actually thought it was more of um
she's alpha widowed
because she dated leonardo dicaprio from
20 to 26.
okay
okay
yeah and um so then that ended and she
was like drinking and partying and stuff
and then she like got spiritual i guess
and like
and so i think she views him as beta
because i think she looks at i think she
looks at um leonardo dicaprio like maybe
she did like thought he was like too you
know wild to be like tamed or like
really marry him or stay with him but i
think she views him as the best that she
could do
well
tom brady
no no
right
yeah i'm saying i think gisele i think
he picked the one girl on the planet
that would view him as beta like like
i'm saying like
because when i say beta i don't mean
that the guy is beta i said that she
views him as a beta not the alpha
well i think like like i think she looks
at leonardo dicaprio as the best that
she could do
and she left because he was too much of
a wild card
but
that now he's still successful he still
has the status
well so here's a i think it's too early
early to determine that because i think
tom brady is more alpha than leonardo
dicaprio
like especially b yeah he he's a
freaking nfl quarter well ah this is
this is rough because and that's that's
what i was talking the problem with very
hot girls is it's very hard to be that
the best that they can do because you
have to compete with like
like all of these guys like a million
like like that she has access to
also well that's impossible one second
one second two dollars super chat thank
you so much thank you we're at two
92 for the sound board okay sorry
continue
well that's why because here's the thing
there's a
he played till he was 43 years old yeah
that's like
he i think he's the longest active
quarterback in
nfl history and people like what's
keeping tom brady going his rich
beautiful wife that's what's keeping him
going mm-hmm
why does he say in his interviews he's
saying that like she wants him to stop
honestly
maybe it's because she's starting to see
she's starting to see signs of his
decline she's starting to see like
cognitive issues maybe you know maybe
she's she's starting to see small things
but that's just like boxers you know
boxers they
they have the will to keep going
football players have the will to keep
going but their bodies
and their brains are telling them to
stop before their will does you know
what i'm saying so she's probably seeing
him having to get it having to get
injections and having to do you know
like he freaking creeps out of bed every
single day and she just she she doesn't
want to see i don't doubt that she loves
him
and she doesn't want to see him get hurt
you know um
so that's probably what it is
a lot of wives to fighters
they they love their man because because
boxers and fighters are alphas
um they don't have the best
financial habits but on a primal so tom
brady is an alpha
on the primal level understand what i'm
saying
which may not translate well to like
romance
i'm a seattle seahawks guy okay and
russell wilson
is a is alpha on the field but in my
opinion he's a simp off the field
because he married
sierra who was a single mom so
maybe let's keep
the case with tom brady but
i don't tom brady he's he he's an alpha
in the primal level i don't think that
leonardo okay who who would you rather
if you had a
if you had to survive
a zombie apocalypse and had to have
someone
lead a team fighting zombies who would
you rather have leonardo dicaprio or tom
brady
uh i mean definitely tom brady see what
i'm saying so so it's just
i i think he wants him to stop because
you know i watch a lot of ufc in boxing
and a lot of ufc fighters and boxers
their wives want them to stop but it's
just because they love them and they
don't want to see them breaking their
bodies
they want to save them from themselves
but that doesn't mean that they're ready
for
their their man to not be at that alpha
status anymore some can handle it and
some can't you know what i'm saying
so so we're going to find out but what
i'm saying is
a lot of these fighters have
above average you know like six and
seven wives or seven eight wives she's a
ten
you know what i'm saying so
we're only gonna be able to find out if
she's gonna be willing to
to because once again in my opinion
she's worth 400 million he's worth 250
million what makes up
that
no one will have more clout in the
public of the united states
unfortunately then then like an nfl
quarterback or like a star basketball
player you know like
from certain positions but he's going to
lose that extra clout like like a lot of
places they go
in america this is just me but
a lot of women might recognize
gizelle lincoln or or guys who say oh
that's like a pretty woman but everyone
recognizes tom brady everybody i i don't
know i think it's his demeanor
like when he talks like
i i just don't how do i put it like
it's gonna sound so like he definitely
has leadership skills but like
i i think like
like leo is a little bit better like
with his words like more of a player if
that makes sense
well like i think i think like like tom
brady comes off as like the nice guy
well and i think 90 of girls would view
him as alpha but i just
i think and it also depends on what the
girl values if she's going to view you
as alpha because you don't know what she
values
and so i think i think it's too on point
that she like married
tom brady during her epiphany phase
right at 29
and like like leo got 20 to 26.
she left him right one like this is all
too yeah
so
here's the thing leonardo dicaprio may
be better with words
okay
you've been an athlete
how many football players star football
players like okay if you're a star
football player you really don't have to
be good with your words because
everything like all all of you want
because of your status anyway i went to
d3 our team was terrible and the guys
did not get girls like that
what i'm saying is maybe basically
i've had friends who were who are good
guys or or star
athletes and like you don't have to
really learn game
you know if you're just like a star
athlete you understand it it wouldn't
surprise me huh
guys let me know in the chat who do you
think's more alpha leonardo dicaprio or
tom brady i'm going to just try that's
not even a question tom brady all day
long guys
put in the chat
who who do you think would win in a
fight i shouldn't even have to ask but
it's not it's not about it's not about
that
it's not about that it doesn't it's not
necessarily who's the most like
like physically fit of who the girl
abuses alpha
it's what that girl values
and like it's kind of like being an
[ __ ] a little bit
look at leo leo brady leo it's it's leo
everyone's saying leo
well
you know i'm gonna have to well i don't
know well
i guess you can say more of an alpha
move
is leonardo dicaprio's um
25 to 27
rotation instead of getting married
and like not dating her and aging out at
24.
yeah that's kind of alpha dude that's
like one of the most alpha things i've
ever heard of tell you too
so just real quick do you think are they
going to stay together or get divorced
what do you think
uh i think they'll
get divorced
how long do you think it's going to take
how do you how long do you think she's
going to take tom brady being around the
house out of shape with just a
commentary gig
i think two years maybe but my question
is i heard one of the articles says
brady's divorcing her
wait so they're actually getting
divorced
well these are all tablet articles so
how reliable are they i don't know but
one of them
one of them said that she's divorced or
he's divorcing her would that
change your opinion on it if he was
divorcing her that like maybe it wasn't
hypergamy
if he were divorcing her
it would just be that she was impossible
and
maybe he'd see because okay i it would
confirm to me that he was playing in the
league to keep his status to be able to
to be seen as an alpha in
her eyes
and maybe he sees the writing on the
wall that though it's gonna
come crashing down when he stops playing
football if
if he were to divorce her he would be
trading her in for a younger version
yeah no he would that's like absolutely
because he's going to be right because
how old is
he
she's 40 something right 41.
so
did you see that one model in her 50s
she was getting that guy from
uh some group and he died and
now she's 56 years old and she's writing
these articles about how she's like
invisible
yeah i saw that
yeah
that's going to be
giselle
if tom brady divorces her she's going to
be late 40s
50s saying it's not fair
that aren't your people don't blah blah
blah blah blah
so you know the crazy thing is she's she
won't be invisible she's still
attractive there's a million guys are
going to see her it's just not the guy
she wants
exactly
yeah like
you really think that model you really
think that model's invisible like she is
not there are plenty of guys her age
it's just the guy she wants yeah exactly
yeah
and that's what that one model was
talking about she wasn't saying all guys
i'm
invisible to you she goes to these
parties where they're freaking
50 100
150 million dollar billion dollar men
and they're just like yeah you're 57
sorry peace
so yeah
if if gizelle were smart she'd realize
that you know there aren't a lot of time
raised they already have kids together
so she should do what she can to stay
with him
but uh it it it could only be a win for
tom if he divorces her
i mean don't get me wrong it would be
good to stay together because they have
kids in the family and stuff but like
you know we're we're not talking about
these are two
extraordinary people you know what i'm
saying
so uh once again is this gonna be
interesting yeah to see when tom brady
goes from you know the leader of the
buccaneers you know what's seven ring he
has seven rings right
seven
ring seven ring tom
you know six six or seven
bring tom to you know tom with the espn
gig up on the weekends and at home most
of the time out of shape i don't think
this is gonna
be able to handle it
so
yeah
no i don't i think they'll divorce too
to be honest but i think i think it's
because she's alpha widowed i think
because he'll never be leo
to be honest
i think look at this this person said
and this is what my i couldn't
conceptualize it this is what i was
thinking brady's got the looks and
career of an alpha but you can tell who
is alpha brother
oh oh god i didn't bed skills i did not
finish reading that comment you never
mind
um
she won't date down she has mill
millions
i
i think if she got out now and like
started dating immediately she could
still probably get a decently high value
guy in my opinion
she should do a janet jackson and
freaking
get with some
some middle eastern oil billionaire or
something like that is that what she did
i don't know you know that jane jackson
got with this middle eastern oil tycoon
billionaire guy for like and then stay
with them for like enough time where she
divorced him and took a whole bunch of
his money she she had a kid by him and
divorced him and just cash out
and she stayed with them like right over
because it's a certain amount of time
where you have to stay with the person
and she like stayed like right to that
point and then just
just deuced out
oh oh wow so she was she didn't even
care about like looking bad she was like
this is what i'm here for and i don't
care who knows it i mean she didn't say
that i say that outright but you know if
you look at the timeline and do the yeah
yeah
is wasn't she rich anyway off of her
yeah but she wasn't she wasn't qatari
and
billionaire rich
oh wow this guy is like a straight look
up janet jackson's ex-husband let me
look this guy doesn't work like freaking
five billion dollars or something like
that
yeah
yeah
oh wow
okay interesting
yeah so i looked it up wow that's crazy
you didn't know who
who
because
i i remember she was like a model in the
90s 2000s she did like a couple of
movies but i i didn't know she was worth
400 million dollars a couple years ago
i'm like what the hell
no i didn't either i mean i was born in
1996 so i wasn't really around when she
was famous like i was pretty young
well i'm really glad
to cover this and only time will tell
and you know it's funny because i hate
brady
but i gotta recognize that you know i
mean you gotta recognize he's the
greatest quarterback of all time and you
know uh
you
he's gonna have a clout he's gonna have
a lot of clout in america because once
again you know like court nfl
quarterbacks go a long way but you know
he'll always be a part of football and
stuff but it's just not the same as
being an active quarterback and getting
on the field you know what i'm saying
it's just not
so
yeah i don't i don't watch football so
that's why i was like i don't even i
barely know the people you're because
you
you're the one who sent me this right
yeah that was me yeah yeah
i knew this was
a good show for you reacting i was like
oh that i was like oh that's interesting
you're like 400 million dollars what
like what do i gotta do and then it was
like oh she's just hot that's it i was
like you can make that much money being
hot what are you yeah
she she's involved like mute with this
beautiful woman in the world like a
bunch of different times
and like all of her movie roles were
just like her being a hot chick with it
you know
and that's it
you know and she has brains because
she's
she has a business empire you know she
isn't stupid but you know like
she definitely milked the looks thing
for all his work you know what i'm
saying and more power to her so
tom brady man i didn't think he was
going to retire this year i thought he
was going to try and push it but uh if
he's 43 he he probably has some stuff
he's dealing with and look at what i
said it before a lot of
uh nfl players have to be saved from
themselves you know
his offseason is filled with
you know cortisone shots stem cells oh
yeah
massage chiropractic you know freaking
all sorts of stuff
he's just you know creaking out of bed
and barely making it through
the season and she wants to save him
from himself but
only time will tell if she's gonna you
know uh this quarantine you know
you have these families
we had to be
around each other and our kids all the
time and we hated each other you know
what i'm saying
i wonder how how she's gonna handle tom
brady being home all the time you know
what i'm thinking he's gonna be home all
the time
now yeah
well yeah i think i think as women we
hate it when you guys are around all the
time like
i think we like think we will like it
but we actually hate it like with guys
just like laying around the house you're
just like
it's like nothing that makes me want to
like like be with you
i want to ask you i want to ask you
a question
kind of off topic but let's see the one
question off topic what do you think of
this whole okay in quarantine
you know
uh because i don't have any kids
uh you know but all these parents were
like stuck around their kids right and
they were like
this is
i literally heard people say you know i
didn't sign up for this when i had kids
i didn't like expect to be around them
all the time
i'm dead serious or like or or or their
spouses like i didn't expect to like
why do you think that that was such a
common thing nowadays where people like
didn't expect to have to be around their
spy spouse especially women
women nowadays were having such an issue
with being around their spouses and or
around their kids all the time because
do you think that like as a woman when
you have kids don't you sign up for the
possibility of having to be around your
kids all the time
uh i don't know i'm asking you i mean i
think
i think some people like like you bring
them to school and stuff so they're away
from you eight hours a day from like
what
first grade
seven hours a day
um
so i think some girls kind of want to do
like the daycare mom thing where it's
like we either put them in daycare and i
like do my own thing
um that wouldn't be my preference but
yeah i think that's kind of what
like why they feel like that is because
they thought they'd be in school or
daycare and now i can't
but shouldn't it be a thing where like
you should be
prepared to be around your kids any time
at all time
is the expectation of like you just have
these kids around
you should but that's not how it is like
like you should but that's not what it
is if you think about it you know up
until the 70s women were around their
kids all the time
yeah
they were
your mom was around kids all the time
right
no
we had nannies we had nannies they were
gone
never mind
no no we had there's too many of us um
no we had we had german nannies from the
time i was like a baby until they
stopped getting them like two years ago
yeah yeah
but
my mom was around like a good amount for
sure like she was definitely yeah
okay well
uh unless you get out here i think it
says two hours but i really appreciate
you covering the topic i'ma watch back
through and see all the research as she
did but i just saw that as you were
going live i was like oh snap hey but
thank you for covering
this topic i really appreciate it
because i think i i fast forwarded to
and you hit on some stuff that
i didn't even know there were tabloids
about them getting divorced so thanks
for doing this video i really appreciate
it yeah for sure thanks for sending it
to me i appreciate it i'll see you later
okay bye
okay
oh my goodness
i'm tired i'm tired i'm tired i'm tired
it's almost it's two in the morning here
okay guys um
thanks for watching i appreciate it
thanks again for all the donations
to
the sound board i think we're at
let me look at the top to see how many
i'm at
i think i'm at like 295 right now
out of the 300 i think it's 295.
um
hopefully we get to the 500 this week
because i'd be dope to order it
by like the end of the month because i
think i'd get paid for it at the end of
the month
so
anyways
uh i appreciate it love you all i'll
talk to you guys next time